the morning reject nation how you doing
happy to be here
Incredibles 2 trailer dropped about 5 in
the morning for us whoo
I woke up at 5:30 thinking I was on top
of it welcome to three text from javi
Kawai my brother be like a drop I was on
top of it anyway before we do this I
want to have a page from the de shout
out to Rosa Parra I was already planning
on shouting her out and normally your
shout outs at the end of the reactions
last night I saw an Instagram that she
had to go into some emergency surgery
pretty sure the surgery went well
already for you I'm happy that it went
well I hope that you're recovering okay
I was really concerned when I saw that I
hope that you recover quickly and
smoothly because we love you you are the
lady stark of our channel so we we just
hope that everything goes accordingly I
hope that your lovely daughter Cassandra
and all your children are paying you a
visit right now and watching this
reaction along with you guys Rosa and
the para artists did you wash your hands
[Laughter]
perceptions about superheroes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
everything's back today with this
villain it looks like Psycho Mantis
didn't quite catch the name but it's a
scary-looking dude yeah man that looked
really scary it seems like above all us
they updated the look and the energy cuz
there's a super kinetic trailer like The
Incredibles is a kinetic movie but this
looks very much of the modern superhero
hey something I just see this ago oh it
looks the same we watch this the other
day you could see that the animation is
actually improved luxury looks a lot
sharper especially now it's watching
last one yeah I mean it's the textures
and the details and the lighting or is
so much richer and I like this trick
because it feels like leaving a lot to
surprise you know they're actually not
giving away a whole lot this stuff here
is just expanded upon images that we
have already seen in the other trailers
okay we know that this is mainly gonna
focus on Elastigirl as the hero Bob as
the stay-at-home dad yeah with Bob is to
stay-at-home dads struggling do that
which is a nice flip because in the last
one it's mainly all about Bob Elastigirl
and the rest of the kids they don't
become like heroes until closer to the
finale of the movie so it's nice to have
that that role reversal there and we're
okay with that I don't think that's a
bad idea
at all for this specific movie all those
motorcycle sequences look like they're
gonna be directed super well because
it's one of the things I love about the
first Incredibles is how awesome the
action isn't that movie Jack Jack's
powers are still very unclear as to what
he's capable of doing cuz yes it's a
wide wide variety of powers know
whatever Elia you do yeah like they just
sort of change on it on a whim with his
mood he's probably gonna be the secret
ingredient again I mean one thing that
radar showing too is that Jack Jack is
obviously gonna suit up this time around
bad parenting there's this one cool
sequence eighties where Dash is running
through like these portals or something
like that yeah I don't know if eyelets
creating that or something this movie
looks awesome yeah it feels like what
we'd want the incredible sequel to
essentially be yeah that kind of looks
like maybe it was alright that we waited
this long for this to happen yes you
because it seems kind of like an
appropriate time to do it and it seems
like you know the the animation
technology is advanced enough to make it
like wow this is significantly updated
The Incredibles is one of their movies
that is more obvious to make a sequel to
it's kind of funny that we've waited
this long has been my whole apprehension
this entire time is like I really hope
that there's a reason to do this you
know and it seems like there is anyway
guys you can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bail
subscribe buttons mean something and
check us out on patreon full-length TV
show reactions weekly Q&A is would love
to have you